Розкажіть будь ласка нащо вам
послідовний
е-е
[музика]
Скажімо так артилерія
робота артилерії - це рятування крою
піхоти
артилерії треба очі
а це є очі артилерії плюс розвідка плюс
супровід диверсійних груп тут дуже
багато дуже багато як його можна
використовувати але якщо я зараз все
розкажу То
це перестане бути таємницею
на всьому Якщо порівняти те на чому я
літав раніше з посейдоном то це як
паперовий літачок і справжній Боїнг Ну
скажімо так от таке от порівняння тому
Ну літав на всьому А чому тоді
тому що я один з батьків постійно
Ну отак ми його вчили літати Це почалося
десь два роки тому новий літак там новий
досвід приїхали зібрали і почали з ними
працювати тобто піднімали Його перший
раз повітря там вчили його літати там
доробляли її перший раз в Україні він
з'явився його передав наш друг сюди і
він з'явився ще
двадцять Ну коротше на початку лютого ще
Ну до 2 до 24 лютого він вже був в
районі попасної він там є вчив хлопців
літати я був льотчик
із тестування Скажімо так
ми піднімали його в повітря там робили з
ним те що можливо і неможливо
з цього робилися висновки
ну мушу сказати що не один ми вбили
для того щоб для того щоб він досяг
якості ну тобто для того щоб літак знати
що він може і він Треба довести до його
краю
іноді край надто близько стає і він
розбивається
але на сьогодні ну
це дуже дуже крута і дуже майже
досконала машина
діти такі до цієї Перемоги а не забувати
що війна йде
От і все Ну це дуже Просто насправді
ми ще вчора були на фронті зранку
Сьогодні ми в Києві Чесно кажучи
є відчуття що люди забули Забули що йде
війна Ну от
я відчуваю от я йду по вулиці Ну і
відчуваю так що
там Трохи інакше світ ніж тут при всьому
при тому що от буквально вот за день
Була нічна Атака така доволі складна і
слава нашим ППО вони просто красунчики
просто the best але от так от щось якось
на людей не знаю що впливає
весна напевно
просто щоб люди не забували на
вкраїні йде війна і той спокій який
зараз є в Києві він забезпечується
сотнями літерами крові хлопці які зараз
там гинуть ну тобто вони Гинуть не буває
дня щоб не гинули люди
люди які там живуть ближче до фронту
вони бачать от ці от швидкі які там
літають там отак от їм зрозуміло якщо
воно їде швидко їде А і їх їде багато то
щось відбувається але тут тут цього Ну
так десь так
А ми вже перемогли
ну тобто знаєте там можна сказати так що
історія вже написана нам просто треба
перевернути ці сторінки
правда вони всі замарані кров'ю але
кінець він один і там написано Happy End
перемога
а потім лежить другий том цієї книги
відбудування країни і це її розвиток